I should get to leave first check my  stats seven catches 121 yards and one  loss you rushing out of here to get your  tips frosted you can't even pick pizza  gotta get that French bread son another  drop you gonna cry again I think you've  already met our new neighbor probably  signed an autograph form watch your  backs  cuz I'm head hug nothing but net  [Music]  Carson Wentz and dak Prescott welcome to  the wild ride of a starting quarterback  in the NFL  I don't think wanna know what the core  anymore  I'm JJ I'm open business is booming oh  crap  get ready for big-time endorsements just  kidding I have them all I don't get paid  enough for this I'm gonna suspend you